nous accueillons en ambulatoire et on en
spécialisation des patients diabétiques
de type 1 les boutiques de type 2 les
femmes avec diabète gestationnel aussi
tous les gens qui ont des problèmes du
poids c'est les services adultes
donc nous commençons notre prise en
charge à partir de l'âge de 18 ans et en
même temps nous proposons non seulement
les suivi médical mais aussi le suivi
éducatif qui est très intéressant pour
la passion parce que il faut savoir que
le diabète se gère surtout par soi-même
dans que les gens vont chez eux
contrôler leur glycémie vont prendre
leurs médicaments vont préparer la
cuisine comment se nourrir comment
s'alimenter quand on a un diabète
quand on est enceinte et en plus on est
diabétique c'est sans nos ateliers de
tous les jours que nous allons proposer
aux patients alors le diabète de type 2
c'est très souvent appelé le diabète
d'une personne adulte ou âgées même si
maintenant la différence en sont un peu
un peu plus flou chez quelqu'un qui en
surpoids qui à de l'hypertension
artérielle qui a dans la famille
quelqu'un qui est diabétique
il ya malheureusement la liste
développer une maladie qui s'appelle
diabète de type 2 en lien avec certaines
épuisement du pancréas suit aussi à une
mauvaise alimentation à l'absence
d'activité physique diabète de type 1
c'est pas du tout la même maladie même
si ce sont les maladies qui s'appelle de
la même façon parce que les symptômes
sont les mêmes dans l'élévation du taux
de sucre dans le sang
or diabète de type 1 touche surtout les
personnes jeunes
très souvent les enfants et est en lien
avec une destruction de cellules bêta
pancréatiques donc les cellules qui sont
responsables de la sécrétion d'insuline
du coup il n'y a pas d'autre solution
dans le diabète des dit pas on peut
traiter ces personnes là uniquement
exclusivement avec de l'insuline
or dans le diabète de type 2 nous
utilisons beaucoup des cachets des
médicaments par voie orale ou bien d
autres médicaments injectables
mais qui ne sont pas de l'insuline
pendant le temps où le contrer à ses
traites encore d'une manière résiduelle
de l'insuline pour arriver à la fin de
l'histoire de la maladie sous traitement
par insuline pour la plupart des
patients le diabète de type 2 c'est une
maladie
qui est décrite comme polygénique ça
veut dire il ya plusieurs gènes qui
favorise l'apparition du diabète et
malheureusement les risques et quand
même élevé si nous avons un parent qui
est diabétique il ya 30 % de risque de
devenir diabétique courant la vie si
tous les deux parents sont diabétiques
il ya 60 % de risque de devenir
diabétique
c'est beaucoup et pas beaucoup parce
qu'on peut toujours dire nous avons
quand même 40 % des chances de ne pas
devenir diabétique
si on fait tous comme il faut mais on
améliore aussi un bon équilibre qui est
quand même essentiel
et puis on peut aussi éviter la maladie
dans le diabète de type 1 c'est pas du
tout la même chose c'est pas du tout la
même maladie quand il ya un papa
diabétique il ya environ 4 % de risque
de devenir diabétique de type 1 auront
la vie pour l'enfant
si tous les deux parents sont
diabétiques et environ 7 8 % de risques
de devenir des batiks donc la
transmission génétique est beaucoup
moins importante alors ce que j'ai envie
de dire ma passion très souvent le mot
qui est mots clés dans le diabète type 1
type 2 c'est la persévérance
comme dans la vie il ya beaucoup de
situations qui nous font baisser les
bras mais dans la dona maladies
chroniques il faut persévérer il faut
essayer de faire au mieux et se soigner
soi même avec nos moyens soigne s'est
soigné soi même ça veut dire activité
physique bonne alimentation avec l'aide
de médicaments que nous avons
actuellement
disposition ses soins les médicaments
très moderne
là les rita de plusieurs années de
recherche qui nous permettent de les
garder pas ça le passage sous insuline
mais qui ne feront absolument pas de
miracle si l'activité physique n'est pas
plaisante et si l'alimentation est
déséquilibré nous à l'hôpital
malheureusement nous sommes confrontés à
avoir des patients qui ont développé des
ja du diabète ou bien qu'ils ont
développé déjà des complications du
diabète donc au stade tardif de la
maladie ce qui est très important c'est
la prévention de la maladie
ça veut dire quoi au juste une bonne
alimentation
une alimentation qui est régulière le
soin de poids donc ça veut dire ne pas
prendre du poids et puis de ne pas
tomber dans la sédentarité ça veut dire
plaindre en compte que l'activité
physique fait partie d'une prévention et
si on parle de l'activité physique à
actions metabolic une activité physique
régulière modéré à très intense mais les
du lierre cinq fois par semaine
d'environ 30 minutes dans la prévention
des complications du diabète quand on
est diabétique
il est très important de continuer ce
qu'on appelle nos dans notre langage
médical mesures hygiéno diététiques ce
qui veut dire activité physique
régulière alimentation bien équilibrée
mais aussi tout ce qui peut aggraver la
teinte de des artères des vaisseaux ça
veut dire éviter la consommation de
tabac
alcool avec modération bien sûr
et puis soigner toutes les maladies qui
vont autour de diabète former le facteur
de risque de maladies cardiovasculaires
c'est à dire de nepal tension artérielle
est haussier de hypercholestérolémie